what is up ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls it's your boy Goblin come check me
out on the bootleg Kev podcast oh yeah
yeah
bootleg Camp podcast special guest
Goblin is here yes sir welcome thank you
for having me thanks for coming man
first of all welcome to La you're our
new La resident yup yup very new
boyfriend obviously you have uh you've
been in Illinois
um what motivated you to finally kind of
make the jump to the big times and come
over here and pay all this tax money
yeah you know hey I'm buckling up for my
first uh my first little tax return out
here but um not really turns you don't
get nothing back you know what I mean um
um but honestly it was mainly two things
a you know the content I already come
out here you know I was traveling out
here so much to hang out with my friends
do podcasts you know do that kind of
stuff
um with the kind of stuff I do you know
making weed videos that kind of thing
um it's like a no-brainer to get out
here because the Illinois weed Market I
don't know if you know a ton about it
brutal is it brutal in terms of
legalities or just so it's legal but
they have at least in my opinion one of
the worst programs in the state they um
they campaigned it on like all this
social equity and like oh we're gonna
you know give you know low income and
people have been impacted by cannabis
laws licenses the first opportunity yeah
yeah the first chance okay and what
ended up being was you know the the cost
to apply a loan was like 250 000 even if
you got denied so immediately so you had
to come up with 250 Grand just to a
quarterback just to apply and then if
they say no you're out of 250 yeah so
immediately the the 99.9 of people that
were supposed to benefit from it don't
qualify right yeah they're yeah yeah and
the 0.01 that do qualify got investors
for it right you know so the market out
there is just a bunch of like the big
companies that came out from the east
coast and you know all the corporations
and just put a bunch of shitty weed on
the shelf and then the taxes the taxes
are crazy yeah I don't even like
um I guess being in La I don't really go
to dispensaries yeah yeah it's different
I guess I'm kind of like I get a bunch
of free weed which you do I'm sure yeah
so it's like
you know I don't know yeah shout out to
the folks paying attention and listen
shout out to the dispensaries I heard it
as a extremely like the like to be in
Cali and be on that side of the business
I heard is very tough tough yeah because
the black market is still where all the
money is yeah as a matter of fact a lot
of these guys are doing both yeah oh
they're all back dooring 99 dude I mean
I you know it's funny because doing what
I do and going to all these weed events
and like networking and stuff you shake
hands with these people and you know you
only know them prior to that from the
dispensary shelf and you think like oh
these guys are super legit they're
[__] serving packs right there to
anybody you know it doesn't they're all
doing it it doesn't get Brands you can
think of shake a dude's hand get them on
Instagram all of a sudden you got a
telegram get whatever the [__] you want
you know yeah the telegram [__] is crazy
it's nuts it's nuts but yeah
um just so they don't have sessions and
[__] out there oh no I mean they have
like some kind of they're either super
corporate or they're super low-key and
like super [__] yeah super scuffed
you know in the shittiest neighborhood
parking like empty your car take the
cups out type [__] you know so there's
there's no real room for like the weed
Market to grow there just because the
laws in the black market they got some
contenders you know there's Brands like
Capone's Garden putting out some fire
out there but that's like the only one
that comes to mind so that's interesting
so when you go to likes because for
people who don't know if in La there's
I mean probably once a week you could
find a dope weed event to go to for sure
like twice a month oh yeah and there's
these giant seshes where you know
they're I don't know how legal or
illegal they are but the cops don't give
a [__] because they're out no so you
walk through and buy packs you could buy
um [__] the last time I went to a sesh I
got [__] uh this LSD spray oh I've
seen that going it almost comes like it
looks like a little bottle of Mace
almost yeah like banaka almost when I
went to the um puffco just recently
launched a new uh like a new device or
whatever yeah and I went to their event
and there was some dude going around I'm
not gonna name the guy but there's some
dude going around just offering people
sprays like yo you want a little LSD
spray where'd that [__] even come from I
don't know but it's not bad yeah no it's
not it's light it's super light I
haven't tried them but you know I
haven't done my ass in a couple years
you know I switched to the shrooms now
right
um if I was still under the acid I'd be
abusing that [__] are you going to the
isn't puffco Fest coming next puff con
isn't that coming with like Action
Bronson yeah they got a bunch of people
uh yeah I'm probably going I mean I have
it feels like the kind of thing you
should be at yeah I mean I haven't like
booked a ticket yet but I mean puffco
they're the homies you know they always
you know hit me up they're like yeah I
got a bunch of cool devices yeah yeah
they're dope yeah they're dope um all
right so for people who don't know
um I recently it's funny because I had
Yola on yep and uh we had been following
each other for a while and I had one of
my friends go on his podcast and I kind
of like dived in and I'm like I've been
kind of oblivious
to the weed YouTube space yeah for a
while I recently got hip to it in the
last like four or five months and I'm
like oh there's like this whole yeah
it's a whole like it's kind of crazy
because you know when I think of YouTube
like being on even like my side of like
the Creator space like man I get flat we
get yellow videos so [__] much I
wouldn't even think that there's like
that and
um and then I found out about you
because I saw on on Yolo's page you've
been on there three or four times I
think five at this point Jesus Christ
yeah um so I watched one of your
interviews and
um I was like oh this kid's cool as [__]
thank you I appreciate that for people
who don't know you kind of came onto the
scene playing video games wow
doing and reviewing drugs off camera
pretty much yeah that was my uh my
initial way that I got a following at
least when I was long a lot younger I
was a degenerate you know I was I was
big into getting high on whatever the
[__] I could afford for the day yeah you
know so
um I kind of came up just doing like
mixing my my gaming stuff right with my
drug use stuff so that was kind of what
put you on the map um yeah so you
growing up like what was your childhood
like like what was your house like you
know
um I mean my I had a pretty good
childhood you know my parents divorced
when I was super young so it wasn't
something that really bothered me
because I just got used to it the
divorce and I was like three you know
yeah that's all you know yeah it was
like hell yeah two Christmases hell yeah
you know mom's fighting dad who's buying
the better gift you know I love that
[__] so um you know growing up my
childhood was pretty good
um as I got a little older got into like
middle school high school it kind of
just started like being a little
delinquent you know going to the store
stealing [__] around at school
um and it I don't really know like what
drove it I think it was either like I
got ADHD have a hard time focusing need
to do like a lot of impulsive [__] to
keep going
um or maybe I was just bored I don't
know but um so you just kind of like
were out of boredom you were just
[__] around getting in like small
trouble yeah you know I was [__]
around nothing really major I had bad
grades in school you know that type of
thing
um and then once I got into high school
and I started meeting all these new
people and like going to you know
parties and like social events and [__]
you know you go to homecoming yeah
drinking liquor in the parking lot type
[__] you know
um that's when I really got introduced
to the stuff that a lot of people now
know me for you know and and see me uh
you know make videos about was it weed
initially
um I drank first but after that yeah
weed was my first thing that I really
picked up like damn this is it this is
amazing uh-huh I um my first time
smoking I remember I was 15 and me and
my friends we went to this little Forest
Preserve and we had rolled this blunt
and it was a swisher or some like
garbage I don't know what the hell we
put in it but you know 15 year old kids
not smoking anything good right so we um
we hopped out of the Forest Preserve we
were walking around and my first time I
didn't really get very high you know I
didn't get what all the hype was about I
was like damn this is it you know this
[__] sucks and then a couple days
later I hung out with the same dudes
again and they were like yo just try it
again go for it you know second time
[__] greatest night of my life like I
will never forget that night
um I it was like it was just I had been
drunk before you know but this was
something different and I was like damn
and it was kind of weird because like
I'd never I never felt anything like
that before you know so yeah the first
time you get like smacked yeah you get
really stoned you're like
man yeah you're just sitting there it's
different because it is way different
than getting drunk yup yup 100 100 I
think I think most people like you know
I think I don't know if like you because
I mean look you're always you're gonna
get higher than the first time you've
been smacked if you keep smoking but I
think oh it's like that first time I
just remember the first time I got like
super high
I got
super [__] paranoid like I I had to
be sativa I was at a party dude and I
just started I had like the Freak Out
High which is like the [__] you see in
the movies yeah I feel you before I had
like the just [__] I'm out bro like
you know but yeah the Freak Out high is
uh yeah that shit's not fun not fun at
all man the heart starts racing you're
sitting there you're like am I breathing
enough so for you you start smoking in
high school yep yeah I was 15. I started
smoking
um my grades were already bad going into
that they were already [__] they were
all yeah I uh my junior year high school
I finished my GPA was 0.8 so yeah I had
below one so they kicked my ass out of
school and sent me to the alternative
school oh love those schools the
pregnant chicks yeah oh so dude so it
was funny with babysitters my
alternative school had less than 100
kids in it whole school and out of that
maybe five of them were girls three of
them were pregnant like on rotation in
any given moment you know it was it was
a trip but once I got sent there is
really where you know my my drug use and
all that kind of opened up because all
those kids are with the [__] oh yeah
yeah you know going into it I was like
oh this is probably just other kids who
like don't really care and then I got
there and I'm like oh these kids are
taking zans for breakfast and [__] like
okay I see you know first period like
before class starts they're smoking
blunts in the [__] stall you know
like okay different schooling super
different it's crazy because when I was
uh in high school
I'm probably older than you I'm 36. so
when I was in high school like uh Somas
were popping so people would like crush
up Somas and stuff
this was before zans were like a thing
like yeah
it was it was Vicodin it was Soma's and
it was weed and then the Mormon kids
would do heroin
dude I don't know what it is about the
Mormon kids from where I'm from shout
out to Mesa these [__] kids always
were getting the girls were getting
[__] in the ass because it was their
loophole to now break their virginity
the holy loophole the holy loophole and
the and everybody else is [__] all
the kids who party that were Mormon were
shooting heroin it was just the wildest
[__] ever yeah I um you know it's kind
of funny my uh my high school is like
big drug of choice they're always like
on the local news and [__] for heroin
ODS because I grew up in like a pretty
nice area with a lot of like just
Christian kids and [__] yeah it's always
those kids yes it's the super religious
kids that go hard as hell they want to
be like [__] your [__] the parents yeah
and they they've been holding it in for
like you know 15 20 however long years
you know they're ready to blow in more
than one way more than one way
so did you start you go from weed you're
15 uh you go to the alternative schools
that restart Dublin and dablin with some
of the more hardcore [__] yeah you know
prior to getting to that school you know
I tried a couple things I'd done the
Xanax you know I tried like getting high
off the cough meds you know so you were
sipping some Lane no no not the lean
like going to Walgreens
[__] yeah yeah I mean I didn't have the
money for lean dude yeah let's try some
NyQuil so yeah we're going to Walgreens
we're hitting the shelves Severe Cold
and Flu yup yup you ever heard of uh
Triple C's I I feel like I've heard of
that the Carissa didn't coughing cold
okay yep yep those little bad boys yup
yeah I think I took one like three
months ago they still make those [__]
and I can't believe it I can't believe
it if you used to take those and just
get [__] up all the time yeah I
remember the first time I took him
um there was this kid named Andrew we
all called him mop and I went over to
hang out with him and he was like
everyone knew him it's just eating
[__] boxes of these things like yo
catch Andrew early in the day he's gonna
be like face down you know like eating
this [__] from the drugstore yeah yeah
eating the Triple C's so he'd eat like
two boxes of these things it was 15
about heat like 30 of these [__] a
day and uh what the [__] I went over in
my first time I asked him I was like how
many should I take and he was like oh
like 15. and I was like oh okay because
I didn't understand like dosages or
anything yet I never done that at school
no I was thank god dude I was face down
on homie's lawn for like two hours
middle of the summer it was like July I
was sweating and [__]
um but yeah so I I like went over there
asked me what to do he told me 15. took
that [__] terrible ass experience but it
was the first alter alternative to weed
and liquor that I was introduced to yeah
so I was like yeah I'm gonna try it
again like take a little less and then I
got real into it and I was like yo I can
bring this to school and just like say
I'm sick I'm sick you know yes I have a
cold so I would [__] I throw the
Triple C's in my bag like every day
after you like put them in your drink
and let them dissolve no I just pop them
you know would you go to the bathroom
take like five or six of them and then
you would you [__] just come back to
class and knock out on your arm like
that see so the whole the whole point of
getting high off the DXM the cough meds
is you got to fight the sleep because
that's when the fun starts so it's like
if you fall asleep you lost you know so
if you if you go to sleep you miss out
on the phone yeah you're missing it all
you know you're missing the the good
[__] and cough meds they're like it's
not even fun really yeah they're the
most like [__] awful like poverty
drug to do like it's really the only
people abusing cough meds are like kids
who have no money yeah poverty drug you
know so uh I uh I just like I remember
just loving like fighting the the sleep
and sitting there in like second third
period and school and just being like
yeah
I'm feeling [__] weird you know
looking at the wall and shit's just like
I got tracers everywhere and like wow
shit's glowing a little bit
so you go from doing that
um when what because because you I mean
is it safe to say you've tried every
pretty like the only I'd say major drugs
or like main drugs I haven't tried meth
heroin fentanyl wasn't really popular in
my area when I was young but now it is
so I haven't really done fentanyl either
no math no no meth heroin fentanyl
haven't done I did smoke crack one time
how okay
I gotta know this because I always I
watched
um snowfall have you watched the show
snowfall no so I've heard of it though
great show right in this show everyone
who smokes crack
they they end up sucking dick for it and
I guess the like you know the stigma
about crack is that it's so good that
straight men will suck dick to get more
of it if they're poor yeah so how was
smoking crack honestly pretty [__] I'm
not gonna lie and granted I might have
had a bit of a skewed experience because
we made the [__] and none of us knew how
to do it so you re-rocked your own crack
yeah yeah we went on we were so we
gotten out of school and I had a buddy
named Ashton and he used to sell a bunch
of coke he'd show up to school and just
like serve kids you know great bags in
the bathroom and [__] one day we get out
of school and he's got a baggie on him
and we get a ride over to my place and
we were originally just gonna chill out
do some bumps and he's like yo I'm
[__] bored of this [__] let's yeah
let's step it up like let's cook this
cocaine yeah let's do some [__] so we
hop on our phones and we start looking
up we were literally just on like
YouTube and [__] just like how to cook
crack yeah and we're on [__] Google
looking this [__] up and there's a bunch
of these little forums that you can go
on that are just in the depth the pits
of the internet like you shouldn't be on
and um we're finding these like
step-by-step guides and [__] and we
found this one because this guy had a
video and it was how to make like a
personal serving and a spoon and we were
like yo all you need is [__] baking
soda you know a little water lighter and
a spoon and some tin foil and a goddamn
freezer and you're in this [__] and we
had all those things so we were like yo
let's [__] try it so we went through
the process you know we took one of my
mom's little spoons yeah we [__]
cooked up on there and then we we
transferred it onto the tin foil after
we'd separated everything we froze it
and we let it sit for like felt like an
eternity probably like five minutes yeah
we were impatient
um and then we pulled it out and we
realized we were like damn we got
nothing to smoke it out of so then we
had to make a little tin foil [__]
crack pipe and smoke it out of that
um honestly it was kind of like
underwhelming and it was probably
because we cooked some garbage like hey
the cocaine couldn't have been great we
were like 16 you know and B we didn't
know what the [__] we were doing you
know so you you didn't you probably
didn't have the uh the full like The
Full Experience
but I did feel it and I it was it lasted
like two minutes if even and it was like
have you ever done Coke I've never done
any drugs but hallucinogenics and weed
okay that's good that's good for the
viewers out there that's good
um I grew up in a house where my aunt my
uncle's all their spoons were burnt okay
I had a bunch of dope fiends yes you
didn't want to be around that [__] you
didn't want to do that yeah okay uh for
me it was the opposite all my spoons
were clean so you're like let me [__]
dirty them up yeah
um so I um
oh God I lost my train no we're talking
about uh you asked me if I'd ever done
Coke yeah yeah so
um
essentially like when you when you do
Coke it's like every time you do the
first line from being like bone server
you just get this like this rush it goes
straight to your [__] head and you
feel it and then it kind of like comes
down so you got to keep doing it you
know right with crack it's like that
rush like you know how when I said with
the coke it kind of comes down over you
with crack
it never comes down over you it just
straight [__] rush and you're it's
like Coke sped up you know you're just
on like a hundred times speed everything
goes by very quickly I got pissed off I
remember I punched my mom's cabinet I
was like yeah like so my friend hit it
and they passed it to me and he was like
yo like this is [__] this is crazy
and I hit it and I was like yeah and I
just [__] sent it through the cabinet
you know I was like [__] yeah dude this
is awesome so you you hit the crack and
then punch your mom's cabinet almost
immediately yeah pretty much immediately
and I was just like me and my friend
were just body boxing each other okay
we're just punching each other just on
crack [__] around yeah just passing
the [__] little tinfoil pipe around
um and it lasted a whole like 120
seconds if even we came down and we were
just like oh that was kind of
underwhelming damn it's gone already
yeah I was expecting a little better out
of that but I also totally get like
crackheads exist you get it because like
yeah because even that god-awful like
garbage crack we cooked I still felt
like you know a little little hey now
you know a little lit
um I could only imagine what the good
shit's like yeah because you always hear
like everybody who does crack there just
they just spend the rest of their life
chasing the first time they did it yeah
which is a very um that sounds amazing
to me which is
yeah you know that's that's I think you
know I'm very thankful that my first
experience with was with shitty crack
this is true because you because you're
not but you might not be here oh yeah if
it was good crack I would have been out
there dude I would have been gone at
what point in time because I I saw uh
you had kind of you've kind of kicked
back a bit on like the excessive drug
use yeah so I'm I'm Cali sober now so
you're a hallucinogenic Swede yep okay
streams and weed are all I've done for
like the past two years well that's
amazing congrats been pretty good thank
you appreciate it what would you say was
your low point with addiction and uh and
the hard [__] were you selling [__]
where you um I mean I always I always
sold like whatever I had but I was never
selling enough to make any [__] money
but I'm saying like were you selling
[__] like did you drive to the point
where you were like oh liquidated sell
something to get [__] to get in there I
sold my [__] once I ran out of that I
was selling my dad [__] I was selling
everything I would go in the garage and
pull out random like Hammers and tools
and [__] and go hit the you know hit the
pawn shop like yeah can I get a can I
get a dub for these like come on man
um but as I I got a little older I guess
what I view is my like actual rock
bottom Point
um when I was like 20 I got a DUI and it
was suck kind of yeah sucks sucks ass so
awful cost a shitload of money to deal
with don't recommend it
um literally like a thousand Ubers is
cheaper than you you know it's it's
ridiculous
um but I got a DUI and then I got kicked
out of my mom's house because I'm still
living with my parents you know I was 20
at the time I'm 24 now yeah
um so I got kicked out of my mom's house
and I had like two thousand dollars to
my name and I was like yeah this ain't
even a [__] deposit yeah
um yeah apartment yeah no not [__] so I
had a homie uh whose brother I bought
weed from and he had this little like
[__] whole house that he was like four
months behind on rent and it was in
Central Illinois a little town called
Springfield bum [__] nowhere
um I mean Springfield if there's it's
the capital like there's a Springfield
everywhere there is yeah every damn
state has a Springfield yeah but
Illinois Springfield is a sad place to
be okay and uh I hear Illinois as a
state is kind of [__] outside of like
yeah yeah nice part of Chicago so if you
go any direction about 45 minutes out of
Chicago you're pretty much in no man's
land like because Gary Indiana's right
there I heard that Gary's awful terrible
brutal brutal it's like
when people like you know they make the
jokes about you know Detroit it's like
how you picture Detroit it's actually
Gary it's actually Gary yeah yeah I've
been in Detroit yeah
Detroit's nice I was just there in July
not a bad spot yeah Detroit's great
um Gary is the real Detroit Gary is the
actual Detroit yeah Gary is a [__]
and it's never coming back yeah
um
yeah any direction 45 minutes out of
Chicago [__] so you you ended up
getting with your boy who was four
months behind on rent yeah and I I took
over he subleased it to me I didn't
realize it was illegally I I just he
told me he was like yeah it's all good
you know landlord's cool with that [__]
he wasn't cool with that [__] so I moved
into this house it was 600 a month right
there was no gas there was no heat there
was no air there was like it was pretty
much walls in the ceiling you know it
was just a [__] yeah place to sleep
that's it we had no stove we had no like
none of that [__] so um there's a place
to sleep though so I lived there for
like two months and I lived there with
two other roommates and then both of
them ended up bailing so I was there
alone I was like yo I can't afford this
[__] probably like what am I gonna do so
I started live streaming and I started
doing this [__] where I would take shots
for donations I'd be like yo shots yeah
shots I'd be like yo I gotta pay my rent
this month I'm like 200 bucks short
[__] hop on go live take some shots
you know so I kind of ran that for like
few months was that your initial like
introduction to streaming
um are you kind of consistent streaming
yes I I had streamed a couple times
prior to that but that was kind of like
what what kind of motivated you to
really do it honestly yeah it was um it
was a I guess kind of a rough way to
start it you know [__] getting black
out drunk every stream yeah
um because at that point I was still
doing the Coke and everything so I was
just getting blackout drunk doing my
bums to keep me going and then drinking
more you know
um
were you on camera doing the shots yeah
okay okay yeah okay yeah
um but you never were doing the drugs on
camera no I would always so I used to do
this thing
um I don't know if I should say what
platform because I'm still on there but
I was on a certain platform where I
would live stream and when I was really
really like big into ketamine I went
through a phase a couple years ago where
I was super heavy into that [__] I would
tell um I'd tell my chat I'd be like yo
the [__] the vet's calling bro about
my like pet horse you know and I'd
[__] lean down and I do my do my K
bumps off the [__] phone and I come
back out and be like Oh horse is good
bro like that call we straight you know
like we good
um and I would do that and they tip you
you know would they tip you yeah yeah I
mean I wouldn't do it for money directly
but like you know I'd be like hey we got
some [__] let's do some K you know
like thanks for the 10 bomb dude like
[__] yeah
um I just couldn't like hold it up to
the camera and do it so I had to be a
little more low-key about it but yeah I
I um sounds like twitch to me
one of the platforms we'll leave it at
that one of them
um but either way I uh that's how I kind
of like got my way out of that house
because the landlord came by on
Christmas day uh and found that like
found all my stuff in there I wasn't
home at the time thank God and the
landlord probably doesn't know you're
living there no does not know he doesn't
think anyone's living there right now
okay so um it now that I think about it
I don't even know if my rent money ever
made it to the landlord because your boy
probably just took it probably pocketed
it yeah probably hey either way I had a
[__] roof you know it cost me the
same either way no matter who went to so
I don't give a [__] but um yeah so on
Christmas Day actually the landlord
pulled up while I wasn't there thank God
and he found all my [__] in there rented
a dumpster and just threw out all my
[__] so I got some stuff out thank God
my computer I got out like I got one of
my computer monitors
um but beyond my computer and like one
of my monitors everything else was in
the garbage wow so I'm sitting there and
I'm like [__] bro like now you know
thankfully I had somewhere else I was
able to go in the same town you know so
I ended up um funny enough I actually
there was a chick who was a viewer uh
who I had on Snapchat who one day she
was like looking on Snap maps and like
saw me down there I was like what the
[__] are you doing you're close by you
know yeah what the [__] you doing in
this [__] hole and she had a house that
she was renting out because her rich ass
parents bought her a crib to live in
with her boy friend the dude cheated on
her so she was moving back to California
so I was like
get me in there you know put me in
um and that house wasn't much better
than the first one but it had you know
fans in it so at least I had some
airflow going you know and we had heat
yeah so I was still doing like the you
know the ketamine the [__] uh the
drunk streams were a big like daily
thing at that point uh so you're just
drinking you're like going going ape
[__] drinking my life away [__]
sorting my life away whatever fits in my
nasal cavities going in you know
um and I I had gotten to a point where
like I wasn't having fun anymore after
like a year and a half of doing that you
know it gotten to the point where I
would like I would get drunk and I'd do
my blow to like like bring myself back
too so I could drink more and I would
just feel my heart [__] dumping and
I'd be tripping I'd be sitting there
like yo am I gonna have a [__] heart
attack today like it was beaten like I
get like done done and then would slow
down and go like done you could feel it
yeah I don't feel it I'm like my
heartbeat like yeah and like there was
one day where I got this I had just done
like a couple lines and I got this
[__] super sharp pain cocaine or okay
Coke okay Coke um but I would mix them
up I would do like the Coke and the K
lines I do the Coke and the Molly lines
just [__] swish it up you know
um which stupidest thing ever they don't
have any Synergy at all like okay like
you're just wasting drugs but they
cancel each other out a bit yeah yeah
somewhat like
I mean especially with K you have to do
a very limited amount of it before like
without k-holing yourself
yeah I actually we just had a guy uh my
boy gorilla Nims was on the show and he
told us a story uh he said he was doing
it and
he said he remembered the date he said
him and this girl were doing it together
and they were [__]
and they both got it he said essentially
it was like July 3rd yup and he woke up
on July 5th
he said I woke up on top of her and we
both like just passed out for two days
and like passed out through all of the
Fourth of July yeah that's the way it
goes dude
um I used to do that a lot off Xanax all
the time I'd [__] go to bed on Friday
I wake up on Sunday and [__] yeah the
Zan shit's crazy especially if you mix
it with the with alcohol dude oh it's
over with it's bad dude you know my
son's uh my baby mama who's this [__]
Psychopathic piece of [__] addict as
well uh God bless her
dude this [__] used to [__] drink
like a fish and then do Xanax and it was
like
she would just die for like 20 hours
yeah I mean she crashed our car into the
[__] apartment complex sign got a DUI
rule oh my God just the word that shit's
crazy though when people drink Andrew's
hands it's like yeah it's like you're
like what are you signing up for at that
point you're signing up for like
zanza the devil man zans are the devil
I've heard zans are rough dude because
and then there's people who just do them
to go to sleep on an airplane uh-huh
yeah I'll just take a Xanax on an
airplane and a number I don't know if I
could I Know Myself and I know I have an
addictive personality because I'm gonna
do the other [__] yep so I'm like if I
take a Xanax
I don't know what happens next for me
Xanax is like
if if you know you have an addictive
personality Xanax is like the mother of
all [__] addictive things you could
try and the reason I say that is because
it's cheap as [__] there's no social
stigma around it like you know heroin or
like math right it's pretty easy to get
real Santa easy super easy yes it's
pretty safe compared to like trying to
get like you know yeah yeah perk 30s
you're gonna and then not be pressed
realistically if if you go to like
Walgreens and pick up a prescription you
know you could pop that you know damn
near the whole bottle and you're gonna
knock yourself out before you're
actually gonna die or anything right you
know what I'm saying so it's it's one of
those things where like people view it
as such a
like not a hard drug almost and it's so
bad it's so bad it's so addictive when
you try to quit that [__] I had a homie
who who tried to quit and he was having
seizures and [__] really like it's bad
you always hear about like when people
try to quit like opiates they they have
I mean I've experienced it with my son's
mom or she was trying to quit she would
have leg pains yeah sick or throw up
yeah it was a lot it's like that with
Xanax too it's bad I've um I personally
never had to really go through the Xanax
withdrawals because when I was doing
Xanax when I finally stopped doing that
I was still in my stage where I just
replaced One Drug with another right
yeah it was like all right I'm done with
Xanax let's take some [__] hydros
like all right done with the hydros
cocaine ketamine whatever it is you know
what uh did you ever have a point in
time where you thought you were close to
overdosing
yeah actually so when I was 17 oh by the
way do you have a lighter yeah
this is a smoke friendly podcast I
assume yeah yeah I watched the Yola
episode I didn't know if you had like a
there's my timer before you started or
anything
hell yeah feel free to uh Ash in uh that
uh lovely lady
what a beauty that's what is that called
back shot Becky what is this
we were talking about it we're like they
should have put a hole where her
butthole is supposed to go to sit your
joint oh that would have been fire maybe
just a little more like a little like a
little thing just to sit it you know
right in there right in the crack that'd
be perfect yep hey it works though damn
hey maybe the V2 yeah maybe the V shout
out to the V but yeah so okay so what
was the the scare you had
um so when I was like 17
um I had taken some acid that I bought
from a homie of mine okay and it ended
up being fake [__] uh it ended up being
what's called 25i
so it's um have you ever heard of like
25 I haven't heard of that no so it's a
it's a research chemical uh uh that's
supposed to be similar to acid but it's
Dirt Cheap like LSD is already pretty
cheap right but 25i is like you can you
know 10 cents for a tab of that [__] you
know like dirt cheap yeah cause like a
tab is what five to ten bucks if even
yeah like two bucks Buck 50 you know
that's so crazy yup yup yeah when I used
to go online and buy sheets and [__]
um it's like when you buy a sheet or two
at a time it's like buck fifty two two
bucks a tab you know it's crazy so um I
[Music]
um
I had taken some [__] that a homie had
bought online from some random vendor
that he never bought from before and
this is back when like you know Alpha
Bay and like all those old deep websites
weren't getting busted yes dark web
stuff yeah dark web stuff
um that's how me and all my homies got
our [__] back in high school just hop on
there [__] get some [__] you know
um dude I just I I have the book
where's it at I have the dark Web book
oh right there American Kingpin it's
about a behind sting it's about the guy
who I see it it's about the guy who
created uh Silk Road yeah Ross uh what's
his name yes the guy who busted him
that's his book and then they and they
kind of I think they made a movie I
watched the movie the movie was [__]
terrible I hope they remake that that
movie because yeah it's such a good
story it's such a good story but when
they did the movie it was like some
indie [__] it just it came out yeah but
yeah so okay continue so you were on the
was it the uh what's it I what I 25
um 25i 21 was called so I 25 is like a
road I uh I took a few tabs and I was
just like [__] tweaking I felt really
funny and I felt this like tingling all
through me and [__] and I thought it was
just like you know maybe I was just
tripping really hard but like I was I'd
done a shitload of acid at that point
this is nothing like anything I'd ever
felt so I was like yo something's weird
and at some point I called my mom
throughout the night literally middle of
the night tripping [__] like 2 A.M right
called my mom and apparently I was just
speaking like gibberish like no [__]
words coming out at all so she was
freaked out because she already knew
about all my drug use and [__] she
called the cops
um because I was staying at my dad's
house at this point yeah my dad didn't
give a [__] bro like he didn't care he
didn't care what I was on my [__]
hair [__] go do it on the lawn you
know like don't do it in here so he was
asleep in the other room my mom calls
the ambulance they show up at my house
and I I started like
I I knew something was wrong leading up
to like her calling the ambulance and
[__] like I knew this wasn't any normal
experience but I didn't realize I was
having a cardiac arrest so as they got
there I get in the the ambulance and
like I didn't really [__] remember
anything right like I don't I had this I
remember very vaguely this kind of like
almost like an out-of-body kind of thing
I was like I just felt like I was like
remembering things almost like I was
like in my head I was like remembering
things but like they weren't like my
like it wasn't me like it wasn't like my
memory you know I was like [__] tripping
the [__] out and I get to the hospital
and I came to a little later in this
room and they had me all in like the
oxygen like they had to like [__] hit
you with the what's it called I don't
really know what they did but they got
you back yeah yeah they got me because
pretty much my last moment of
Consciousness that I really remember was
like kind of first being in the
ambulance and then there's a big gap
where I don't really know what the [__]
happened until way later once I was like
in the hospital bed like parents they
are chilling so
after that because I was still a minor
um I had no say in whether or not I got
sent to like a facility or anything over
that uh in the state regulations were if
any like minor suffers like a drug
related like overdose or incident they
immediately go into the psych ward for
evaluation so did you have to go in
I'm a two-timer and it's like twice
actually
um so the first time was when I was like
16 but it wasn't like an overdose
um it was because I got arrested for
some dumb [__] and they were like you
know [__] put his ass in there you
know
um but the second time around you know
they sent me in there and they ended up
shipping me up to Minnesota to a
residential facility for like two and a
half months kind of like a rehab time
yeah yeah it was a rehab it was um it
was called Hazelden it was uh like a
pretty nice one I've had a bunch of
people in my comments try to guess I've
never said it so now Hazel now they know
yep was it 12 uh because they're you
know there nowadays there's so many
different I grew up my uncle like I said
all my family's addicts my uncle's like
a legendary drug addict yup this guy
used to shoot up in his like in the
corner of his eyes oh that's heavy used
to shoot up between that's hardcore
shoot up between his toes shoot up in
his underarm so he wouldn't have tracks
yep uh
this guy's [__]
a maniac turns into a [__]
millionaire opens a drug rehab so I grew
up
working for him for minimum wage from
the time I was like 12 to like 18 yeah
around crackheads like I'm literally my
teenage years I work for my uncle in his
businesses that are fully employed by
people who are in his rehab yup so I'm
just I'm hanging out with just grown
convicts
sex offenders drug addicts at all
[__] times
and um it's crazy because nowadays like
that's straight 12-step program which is
very strict you know but nowadays it
feels like there's like
like cannabis
like therapy like yeah they got all
sorts of [__] they got the psilocybin
I'm a 12-step so yeah the 12-step you
got to do so so how far like did you buy
into that at any point no no I uh I mean
I get I think what works about it for
people is not necessarily the actual
steps but just the routine you know
because it gives you some sort of
routine yeah going to a meeting every
day yeah exactly you get a chip you know
drug addicts and and you know alcoholics
in general they don't have a routine
they lack that [__] yeah so you get a
routine in there and now they're good
yeah you got to go to a meeting you
gotta for me it didn't didn't do it
would you ever have a sponsor I did yeah
did you ever call the sponsor
um okay I might [__] do some ketamine
right no I never my first like I was so
I went to a few meetings uh once I got
out of the residential place I had to go
into like Outpatient Treatment still
um and they were requiring me to go to
meetings in order to like get discharged
from there yeah because you had to go
yeah and be checked that you were there
yep yep yeah I had to do the whole damn
nine yards you want to hit this by the
way yeah sure why not what is it what do
we got here um this which one did I open
this is from La family farms uh it's a
donut so nice little
stick of rosin in the middle I honestly
don't remember what strain
but I like the glass tip yeah yeah they
they get them done they're a little um
a little like this is a different glass
tip though yeah I know you normally
don't see them like that sticking out
and everything normally yeah that's
different tiny and in there but that
[__] I like it I'm not mad at that shot
I think these tips are new actually
because I don't but see I've never seen
those yeah I don't remember these tips
I've seen pre-rolls with the glass tips
but they're just like the kind of the
normal ones that you see yep damn the
hole in this is kind of disappointing
though I see that that's it's pretty
[__] that's what she said that's what
he said so you get out of uh you go to
outpatient yep
this is how old are you at this time 18
18 yeah I turned 18 while I was in rehab
so you turn 18 in rehab you get out you
end up by the time you're 19 is when
this apartment thing happens right uh I
was 20. so 20. at what point in time
did you realize
people liked you on the internet and you
could kind of like you had a little
niche going like so when I um when I
went into rehab I posted like literally
I was sitting in the car on my way to
Minnesota and I posted this video I was
just like yo guys I'm [__] going to
rehab and I'd already been like telling
some some drug stories you were already
kind of like doing your thing on YouTube
yeah to whatever level yeah I had like
17 18. 7 000 subscribers six or seven
thousand that's not nothing yeah no I
had a I had a pretty good amount
um and I was just sitting there and I
was I was tripping so I was like damn
bro I'm gonna be going for two months
and no videos like my shit's gonna be
dead when I get out you know I was
freaking the [__] out
um and I just started to gain like a
little bit of traction yeah my first
couple thousand I was like [__] dude
like this is it you know and I went into
rehab I had like seven thousand I
remember while I was in rehab one of us
got access to a computer and the first
thing I was like yo [__] go on let me
see where I'm at let me see this [__]
and I was at like 13 000. you're like I
didn't even do nothing I was like what
the [__] happened my rehab video blew up
yeah one of my one of my videos popped
the [__] off
um and it got like you know like ten
thousand fifteen thousand views and I
was like damn like this is it bro like
I've never even broken 10K views before
give me the [__] out of this [__] ass
facility get me out of here now bro and
I was like that gave me that that
motivation to just suck it up and get
through you know I was like [__] dude
um so I got out I had like 13 000 Subs I
got home and it was like like you know
how like when rappers get out of jail
and they drop the first day out of
course I dropped my rehab videos and I
was like yo I've been waiting I've been
cooking this [__] for months you know so
I dropped like what is in my opinion
probably my best videos I've ever made
um I just did a series where I just
documented my entire [__] stay in
rehab oh that's it and just discussed
the whole thing [__] everything that
went down there were you able to film in
rehab no because you can't have a phone
right no it was just like gameplay
stories oh gosh you've got commentary so
you're kind of just like playing games
telling your story yeah I had nothing to
do in rehab but read books and write
[__] so I was just taking notes I was
like yo this is I'm gonna do this
[__] series I'm gonna talk about this
this this you know leave out this
information this guy's name you know
whatever just like plotting it out and
I've never in my damn life put that much
thought into a video it's hey what up we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our folks and my bookie that's
right now look
I'm a big Gambler love gambling love
sports gambling I have been on a tear
look I ain't gonna lie to y'all NFL
season so far been real good to your boy
you could get down go to mybookie.ag
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg and uh you know what's great
about that promo code is it's going to
get you hooked up with uh 50 or more
your first deposit you can get up to 200
in cash straight to your my bookie
account with the promo code bootleg at
the end of the day Aaron Rodgers season
is a wrap my guy tore his Achilles it's
over your season doesn't have to be over
NFL college ball man the new cash out
system on my book is crazy let's say you
got a three leg par leg a four leg
parlay maybe three of the four legs have
hit and you're waiting maybe on Monday
Night Football to see if you hit all
four but you don't want to take that
risk you just want to cash out take your
money and run you can do it that brand
new cash out system is fire alright so
make sure you go to my bookie right now
man so much to do all kinds of daily
odds boosters same game parlays huge
prize pool contest right now
mybookie.ag all right sign up use the
promo code bootleg on your first deposit
of 50 or more you can get up to 200 in
cash instantly to gamble with plus we
got a shout out to our fam at
blue chew that's right this is a good
thing about Bluetooth guys
well one you know the one thing I always
get asked about Bluetooth is one does it
work
two do you use it well yes on both
Accords all right shout out to Bluetooth
it works but you gotta that not take my
word for it get a whole month for free
right now if you go to bluetooth.com and
use that promo code bootleg they're
gonna send you a month's supply of
Bluetooth straight to your door for free
just gotta pay five dollars shipping
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis and when I tell you that your
dick is going to be [__] your Johnson
is going to be johnsoning
your [__] is going to be rocked up
socked up and ready to unload yeah it's
like Barry Bonds seven he was a 73 home
runs 70 home run season you're gonna be
knocking them [__] right over the
[__] ho what's what's the Big Green
Monster in Fenway Park [__] your dick's
gonna be hitting hitting that [__]
straight over that wall you know what
I'm saying or whatever you're into you
know don't gotta be [__] could be
[__] whatever you're into
bluetooth.com put your best foot forward
when it comes to your dick all right you
don't want to go on a first date with a
young lady who you think is you know
easy enough to [__] on the first date
and not be prepared get the Bluetooth
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free same active
ingredient as Viagra Cialis no awkward
doctor's appointment uh it's all online
discreet packaging straight to your door
in a chewable Forum bluetooth.com promo
code bootleg let's get back to the crazy
because you always hear Mr Beast talking
about like the science to like and every
video he does there's so much thought
yeah into each one and it he's like yo
like because some people just kind of
they they do videos just because well I
gotta put a video out this week yeah so
it's almost like you said like you gotta
that probably took you to a whole nother
level because you put that much thought
into it yeah you know I had um I'd put
that out and it's like you know I had
already gained some [__] while I was in
rehab and after that you know I got out
and I was also on probation at the time
that I got out of Reason did you have to
piss test yeah yeah I was getting piss
tested and it was it was actually pretty
[__] so
I was smoking a shitload of weed before
I went in I got out of rehab two months
after and I was still pissing dirty so
they thought that I was really yeah yeah
I'm a bigger dude you know somebody so
that THC really stays in me all right so
it took me like three three and a half
months to piss clean because yeah for
people who don't know usually they tell
you two to three weeks that's such
[__] bro right it's different for
everybody it really is I know like thin
people who have pissed dirty dude I used
to have to piss in the pill bottles for
my cousins when they'd go to the [__]
the PO yeah like literally pee in two
pill bottles for my cousin all the
[__] time you're a real one for doing
that too yeah we always love those
homies and then like I think eventually
they just started watching you piss
they're like oh dude they're staring
right at my nuts bro like and then they
started selling fake dicks yeah you saw
a fake dick dude so I was trying
everything in the [__] book just so I
could get stuck you would drink the uh
one time would you drink that tea yes
yes the gallon yeah dude you know all
that [__] is it's literally those little
like uh cleansing drinks if they sell
bro it's just flavored water and two
vitamin B pills to make your pissing off
that's all it is there's no ingredients
dude you could just make your own like
yeah literally you can go get a gatorade
and do it at home that's what I'm saying
crazy
um but I tried all that [__] I remember
online dude they got these whole like
waistbands with the [__] [__] on it
and [__] you can get it's crazy did you
get the [__] waistband No No I um so
while I was on rehab I was just doing
[__] besides getting stoned that
wouldn't last as long in my system so I
was just like taking zans you know do a
little bump here and there and a little
ketamine I was just you know because I
had been in rehab for two and a half
months it was easier for me to like Pace
myself were you um
on colors where it was random uh no or
you kind of knew maybe I knew well
that's that's a positive they let yeah
they let my ass know I was so thankful
that I wasn't on colors
um because I had homies that were on
colors and they were constantly getting
[__] over yeah it was just like hey
surprise you gotta pee today off yeah
[__] constantly and those [__]
weren't quitting you know they weren't
they weren't gonna stop smoking none of
my friends were so
I was like you know pretty committed to
just as long as I don't get stoned I'll
be straight and uh my PO ended up liking
me a lot and uh I would go and you know
I got no tattoos or nothing I look like
a little bit hey what's going on yeah oh
hi how are you oh I've been great you're
like Drew Carey's kid yeah yeah and I
got and I had a job and everything bro I
was I was selling [__] bathtub
remodels and [__] about family models
um so I went in and I you know looked
good on paper
um she liked me so much dude she gave me
a five dollar McDonald's gift card and I
got off and she she told me she was like
all right you got two months left on
your probation I'm not gonna test you
anymore and I thought she was [__] I
thought she was trying me I was like oh
sure yeah for sure okay and I went home
and I sat there and I thought about it
and I was like I've waited so [__]
long like I've waited so damn long and I
folded I folded I went over to my
friend's house took one hit off a blunt
and it was over with and uh she actually
was like of her word she never she never
texted you yeah she actually never
tested me so that's her PO man she's a
real one I said I feel like that's such
a that's such a like Fox yo I feel like
being a probation officer would be such
a fun gig yeah dude because you could
just [__] with people all the time
because like their freedom is in your
hands it's [__] up that I say it that
way but it is kind of the case and you
could just call and tweak on somebody
because 100 yup like hey yo what are you
doing
yeah if one of your if one of your like
like if you were like like for me as a
as a guy who's like a prankster and a
real [__] I would love to be a PO
of that would be pretty fun yeah you're
a [__] great game you just show up at
someone's crib on it now it's just like
hey yo [__] getting high
what are y'all doing in here what's
going on here are you violating
who are you hanging out with no gang
members no Associated gang members guys
yeah damn that's crazy that would be a
sweet gig I mean if you had ever be
better than being a normal cop oh 100
yeah because there's I mean I feel like
for the PO there's just like your job is
to harass people yeah and like less
danger you know if I was like a normal
cop I'd be like do you ever watch Super
Troopers no oh it's so good these
[__] guys dude they just [__]
those fools are just like [__] with
people it's it's a it's like an old
school like early 2000s comedy and these
cops just
they just [__] [__] with people like
they pull people over
they'll go in you ever see Super
Troopers oh my God it's so good it's
missing out I don't know if you're
missing out because it's one of those
movies that like you kind of had to be
there uh
I'm not sure how it aged
it's my mom's favorite comedy so it's
old white ladies enjoy it
um
I've been around a lot of that [__] I've
seen a lot you ever watch uh
not Reno 911 Tacoma fire department on
like True TV I've watched I probably
have because I used to just sit there
and watch True TV channel never watching
practical jokers yes yes so good it is
it's so bomb it's so stupid like some of
the [__] they come up with is just like
so hilarious I'm so mad that Joe Gatto
left he did yeah it was my favorite when
two seasons ago
I had no [__] idea you left man and
so this they're still doing it too yeah
but they do like a celebrity
pranker every episode oh
dude just run it with three
so they'll have like post Malone did it
Joey Fatone who's a regular on the show
I mean that's cool but I feel like
they're just doing that for it's pretty
good dude hey look I think Impractical
Jokers like I really
I've met everybody there's like random
people that I get excited to meet and
those those guys
Larry David
I already met Joe Rogan that was cool
but like if I'm at the Impractical Joker
dudes I'd be pretty stupid I would be
hype yeah I would be pretty [__] that
one dude is pop uh Joey's [__] He's
popping on Tick Tock yeah he's doing his
thing he's on a tick tock he's popped up
on my feet a few times [__] are you
being on Tick Tock no I get banned for
everything I do on there I was gonna ask
you like doing the type of content you
do you're you're smart and where you
don't do that certain [__] on camera but
um how is your monetization intact I
have no ad Revenue so that's my main
Channel
um it was like March of this year oh wow
that's not bad yeah so you had a good
run oh I did I had a great run it was
awesome yeah the ad Revenue was looking
good uh and then they uh they came in
and they clapped me and actually so it's
not permanently taken but I know damn
well I'm never getting it back you have
a temporary yeah I've reapplied uh
because I have to reapply again if I
want to get back into it
um it's just like a suspension or
whatever but the problem is as well the
money they owed me I don't get unless I
get reapproved which kind of [__]
sucks
so so you see the number they owe you
yeah I know you can't even get it yeah
so I was like owed payment for about
three weeks you know three quarters of
the month a month of March and they just
cut off my monetization you know right
before April and then never paid me for
March oh so yeah yeah
um I guess it's not as bad as Yola's
situation was you know yeah he told me
he had like 3.1 million dollars yeah
yeah he he does he does which is crazy
that's yeah I couldn't [__] dude I
think I would go insane like I would I
would you know there's um
there's this girl that went viral
she said that she was
she was [__] dudes online that worked
at Facebook just to try I saw that to
try to get her IG page back if I'm YOLO
bro I'm I am going to try to [__] dudes
that work at YouTube
honest to God yeah yeah yeah
but Instagram you don't got to do none
of that [__] that chick was tweaking
it's super easy to get your Instagram
back nowadays I didn't know that the
system is so abusable dude I just had it
happen the other day I got banned I was
banned for a total of two hours
um there's there's dudes who you can hit
up who can get your Instagram unbanned
and all they want is a shout out on
their Telegram
it's all they want
um the the system's so abusable that
it's like
people like they go around and they like
try to like extort big Instagram people
they'll be like yo I'll [__] Master
Port your page or else you know unless
you pay me like pay me 1500 for the
unbanned you know I'm kidding something
you just did it to me the other day yeah
some guy some guy hit me up uh he was
yummy he uh he commented he was like yo
like reply to my DM or no more Instagram
you know and he's one of those kids who
like
um you can just tell them other type of
profiles bro like listen I don't profile
people often but you could [__] you
could tell the people who are going to
get your Instagram deleted just go to
their account and look at them what they
do is they have bot accounts pretty much
yeah they Mass report you for like fake
identity it's always an identity related
thing so they and that's pretty easy to
clear up uh yeah well not if you have to
get one of those people who can do it to
undo it right so there's good actors and
Bad actors in this space of people who
abuse Instagram shitty system is this on
the dark web you're finding these folks
no no no they're just like on Instagram
bro
yeah those people are on IG yes yes
yeah how cracking is your telegram
um I mean I don't have like my own page
or anything yeah like I don't I don't do
anything on there I just is that you
think that's the new dark web in terms
of like buying drugs I mean before
people were buying [__] off telegram
they were hitting people up on Snapchat
because they thought it was gone forever
you know but it's not before Snapchat
you know even WhatsApp ain't gone
forever no it's not yeah yeah no it's
not uh before [__] Snapchat people
were messaging on Kik and [__] oh Kik
back in the day yeah way back in the day
yeah Kik was a thing I thought about
kick so it's always been just like
whatever platform people perceive is the
most secure what was the other one
signal signal yeah that's a fairly big
one
um
I don't know I think it's it's different
dark web is super different than just
like a telegram trap dark dark web still
popping 100 but it's it's just sketchy
now like the problem is these websites
there's like a new website every like
three months and they come in get a
bunch of money shut down and it's just a
gamble of can you buy at the right time
so you don't get [__] on you know so
your money doesn't get yeah so your
money doesn't get taken because like the
feds are on this [__] now you know they
they understand what it is they know how
to like find these people yeah I always
do it I remember
three four years ago we're at the radio
station and
oh me and my boy DJ damage we were
watching um
like this dark web documentary on Vice
mm-hmm
during our show we had this [__] on the
TV and
well [__] it I'm gonna download the
[__] browser what's the browser
called tour yeah whatever [__] called
if I download the browser and we go on
like uh
whatever like we went on one of the
websites it's almost like Amazon but
like for like whatever you want you know
we're just scrolling I'm like this
shit's crazy it's not it's dude like
it's actually insane like whatever you
want
um
[__] buy it on the site if you if
you're a rapper and you want Spotify
plays yep you know what I'm saying yeah
they have that [__] like if you want a
[__] AK-47 or something if you want
yup how sketch is that because you okay
so when you're buying [__] on the dark
web you have to send crypto correct yep
so you send the crypto and then it's in
God's hands at that point so what
happens is
um essentially how most sites work is
you deposit your crypto on there you
know
um so you have like a wallet and people
have reviews yeah people there's full
reviews profile seller profiles bro
yeah yes it's literally like Amazon for
a legal [__] yeah it's Amazon for
illegal [__] it's it's like imagine just
think of like the black market online
that's literally what this is like it
it's exactly what you could imagine like
if as someone who you know maybe there's
someone out there who's never been on it
like it's probably exactly what the
[__] picture it's just [__] drugs
stolen credit cards you know yeah you
can oh my God you and you could buy fake
money yeah fake counterfeit money
everything bro gun parts and [__] like
everything you want so in the dark web I
was so close
to being like I'm gonna buy it two
thousand dollars dude see if I could so
my friend get it off at a liquor store
my friends used to do that in high
school all the [__] time they bite
off the dark web yes they would buy uh
they'd buy like fake bills and you could
buy them at a pretty good rate you know
it'd be like 20 bucks for a hundred
bucks you know type [__] so you could
get how was the money
did you ever see it yeah oh yeah bro my
friends are riding around with [__]
like stacks and half of it be real and
like half it be fake and they'd be
selling weed and they'd be finessing
people like yo throw a couple hundreds
yeah but a lot of them were really
[__] because like if you could tell
holding the money once you touched it
it's over like maybe from afar you're
good but if a marker touches that [__]
it's over if you touch it it's over you
know yeah the thing about money is it
has that it's that paper it's that paper
you can't replicate it you can't yeah
it's like it's no matter what and you
can beat the [__] out of the uh that's
why I was like nah [__] that I was just
like I want to order something off the
dark I never did yeah but I definitely
um
I definitely was surfing and that [__]
was gnarly we were at the we were doing
that [__] on the iHeartRadio Wi-Fi
we're just like I think for like an hour
me and DJ damage were just like bro what
do they got what what like you could
literally buy someone's whole credit
card [__] oh yeah if you Social Security
if you want to scam they got all the
equipment to scam oh it's [__] crazy
you could buy a fake identity on there
like I've seen so I of course I've spent
so much time just browsing those sites
you know I I would go on so there were
certain Forums on there that you could
go on and see listings of like new sites
and people would review these sites like
well I give this site a trust Factor
rating of six out of ten seven out of
ten it's not that trustworthy the owners
are these people they haven't been
established that long you know like that
kind of thing
um and you go on these sites and you
just look around dude there's like full
identities you can buy like ID passport
social like of like actual yeah like
dead people
so it's like they advertise like yeah
like these people are [__] dead like
you're good because you don't want to
buy like a live persons like if you're
trying to like use a fake identity you
don't want to buy like you know a live
person so I remember reading one more
time it was like in the description like
you can get like a [__] dead person's
one just hit me up you know like write a
message you know and I'm like damn that
wouldn't be a bad idea if victimless
crime
and it's not a bad idea to just have a
backup identity
honestly yeah if [__] goes hey you could
buy worst [__] no 100 100 I wish I had a
backup identity I Wish I Could Just
Dance victimless crime they're dead gone
and then you're like you know what [__]
goes left I'm this other guy yup yup
something to think about Cyrus yeah
backup identity would be gas
avoid tax oh that's that's really the
play damn you get all the payments to
the to the dead guy yeah but they're
gonna catch on pretty quick then when
you're filing taxes for a dead guy right
yeah I guess you're right okay but one
day though like would the IRS check like
like how would they know if the dude's
dead you know that's the it's just
probably just situation the situation
with the dead person damn [__] so you
may maybe you need to get someone who's
been dead for a little longer so the IRS
doesn't remember them I would just be
scared buying [__] were you scared the
cops are coming oh bro every time bro it
felt like I was in a movie like walking
outside of my house like looking around
like [__] it's supposed to get here bro
like
it I remember the first time I ever got
anything in the mail it felt like the
day of it the day was supposed to come
I was so scared all day
um I think the first thing I bought was
just weed I'm pretty sure I I mostly
just bought weed off the deep web it was
a good weed yeah it broke yes back in
high school
um I mean the the people who would sell
us [__] kids we'd like were finessing
I have a friend uh who is facing
serious prison time he got caught up
a dark web fentanyl ring oh that's bad
he is going away
for a long time yeah that's really
[__] bad and it was like he was
already on probation for work for Coke
and I'm like dog you're I had no idea
this guy was doing this [__] I thought
because he was a rapper yep my boy man I
hope I hope everything works out for him
but he's an artist in like um
someone I was real close with and uh
I always thought he was just just moving
packs you know oh yeah packs you know
yeah just a little oh no a little
something no no serious fentanyl which
is a serious thing that that [__]
[__] put you away for life oh yeah
yeah they don't play with that [__]
right now dude I mean rightfully so it's
a very 100 people you are literally
dying all over the place and you know
like as much as also like I have
sympathy for your friend and stuff at
the same time fennel dealers like [__]
it's terrible they should that's bad it
is honestly like it's like dude you're
dealing death Loki literally yeah and
you know that [__] and the whole and
it's like dude like it is crazy because
it's like you know if someone sells weed
I get it even if you're selling crack
whatever but that fentanyl is different
bro yeah that's just straight that's
murder dude especially I'm sure Illinois
is probably crazy with that huh I feel
like middle of the country is just
[__] when it comes to like over here
yeah so
it's um I have a lot of friends from
high school who um ended up graduating
to doing heroin and [__] and it was just
like that progression of
you know first everyone's taking oxy
he's taking the hydros then they
graduated to oh we're just snorting
heroin you know we're not [__]
shooting it up then it's like oh we're
only shooting up on weekends you know
always and his hair was cheaper than
getting pills right yeah yeah yeah
heroin's more efficient like at the end
of the day like the the amount of it you
need to get super [__] is far less
um and then after that you graduate
defense some people don't go to the
heroin part now especially nowadays
because all half these pills are just
fat yeah you know they don't even
realize that they're yeah they don't
even realize that they already have like
a heroin now is all fentanyl good luck
finding real heroin on the street
nowadays you know I I'd imagine [__]
probably 90 of that [__] is just fat now
it's yeah dude it's crazy too because
recently I had hooked my boy up with
another boy of mine who you know deals
and
we were in my hometown he bought
he didn't buy much they buy like a gram
nothing and
he did it we went to my club
the next day he's like yeah I I forgot I
had a kit in my suitcase
and he's like bro that [__] was positive
for Fentanyl and I did a bunch last
night
oh God I was like [__] are you good bro
but I I think it it it's every It Feels
Like Everything has some trace of that
[__] in it now yeah I mean a lot of
these dudes making these uh you know
these drugs and [__] they don't clean
their equipment you know
and like I don't [__] matter
I just saw recently
there's weed fentanyl lace weed which is
very strange oh I'd be so [__] pissed
if someone served me some family have
you heard about that no actually yes
dude I just saw this there's like they
found like weed that tested positive for
Fentanyl
I don't even know where was it at dude
what the f not in Cali it was in the
middle of the country I'm like how the
[__] does that even make sense what are
you like
how does that happen
damn that would be imagine just like
trying to smoke some weed and you end up
doing fat like that's so [__] up when
did you get uh super into psychedelics
um probably right after I got to
alternative school so I was uh you know
I was 16 going on 17.
um
pretty much from 17 onwards is when I
was really super into you know at first
it was acid I didn't like shrooms uh
when I was younger the first time I took
shrooms I did like three and a half four
grams and I was
I I was not ready I was not ready for
the first time yeah yeah so I was my
friend uh my buddy Ashton I don't think
anyone's ready for that oh yeah that's a
huge dose I haven't taken that big of a
dose since yeah yeah [__] yeah you
[__] signed up for [__] a talk
with God that night yeah like two two
and a half is my you know Chill Zone
so that was your first that was my first
ever time doing shrooms
just
I was I was super nauseous and I ended
up like laying in the lawn of some
random person's house for a little bit
to like chill out
um kind of the same thing I did off the
Triple C's you know yeah crash out on
lawns a couple times but um I crashed
out on the lawn and uh my homies were
like yo get in the car get in the car
like this this is not our crib like get
in the car you know and like the lights
were turning on on the porch of the
house and [__] and I got back in the car
and then we the problem is I took this
dose and we had nothing to do we were
just driving around
so like I'm sitting in the back of my
mom's [__] Honda CRV that she let me
borrow for the night you know I feel bad
man damn yeah shots here Mom she had to
be real real one real one yeah my mom
was the homie yeah yep
um she's like I know my kid has a mild
drug problem
go ahead and take the CRV with your boy
yeah I honestly I look back at it like
if I was hurt I would my kid would not
even touch the door handle of my car you
don't even know you can't even go in the
garage like we used to take my mom's
card
and
egg people oh yeah oh [__] yeah dude
[__] yeah there's this one chick
um that one of my friends insisted that
we egg like all the time to at least
like four times but we used to egg
people walking down the street like
every other weekend me and my cousin
Matt I was like 13 he was 16 with his
license and it was like a car of us and
bro there's a Street in Phoenix called
Van Buren where all the prostitutes used
to be we used to eight oh [__] out of
them and then like one time we got
chased by a pimp and an Escalade we
thought we were gonna die we did not die
um we and then we'd stop we were [__]
up we'd have a squirt gun
filled with like
I forget what we used to oh like soapy
water and like the hookers would come up
and we just light them up
Tara I was terrible this is the kind of
guy I was no I've done [__] like that
before dude not to hookers though
because you know in Chicago they're in
the real rough parts of town I don't
want to drive through but
um
out here they're pretty plentiful
prostitutes yeah yeah there's a street
called fig I see a [__] oh yeah yeah
I've heard a fig
there's a guy who who uh flies his drone
all over fig and like gets right up on
the prostitutes I actually I think I
watched like a clip of that on Twitter
earlier too definitely did that's just
hilarious yeah one of them like threw
some [__] at it they were like and then
his whole goal is to find each hooker on
Instagram and he finds them and then
tags him damn that's next level so he'll
post the video of the girl and be like
if you know her IG tag it damn and then
like they like you'll like click on it
oh this is this bitch's page like this
chick who's selling her [__] on fig is
like also on the gram selling her [__]
damn yeah there's definitely I mean I
feel like Los Angeles
got to be a big prostitute place you
have to have it's the just tons of
people over here a lot of people try to
make it as actresses got to get their
money somehow
oh yeah are you I saw you said you were
in a relationship are you still in that
relationship I am yeah this is with uh
somebody whom which you met through your
channel Yes actually won a contest uh no
no
um
what ended up happening was uh it was
someone who just like been in my twitch
chat a lot I didn't know it was like a
girl or anything uh but I have this
thing in my chat where you can um like
like redeem points for a follow and uh
she redeemed one
um I followed on Twitter and I was like
all right you know
hit the little DM oh you're a girl okay
yeah like she had her age in her bio I'm
like
that yeah how you doing
um yeah we've been dating for like a
couple years so should we move out here
with you yeah yeah all right so it's
been pretty chill yeah it's definitely I
I you know I wonder what the like
you know there's groupies for hip-hop
artists there's groupies for athletes I
always wonder like for you do you have
to deal with like a weird type of fan
that like sends you random DMS
not really I've had like
some like big fat chick with her
controller in her hand and a bag of
Cheetos and she's like goblet I'm
playing with my [__] every night to
your voice thankfully no but I mean I've
definitely had some weird fan encounters
but nothing nothing like nothing over
the top no no nothing like that at all
um
got a little Ash on the table again
you're fine you're fine yeah it's it's
sexy Red's [__] was on this table oh
damn okay
what part of it
she was doing all kinds of photoshopping
Day photo shoot dancing actually I think
the table has been
did we repaint it
oh yeah Christian rock she carved into
the table we uh we sanded it out I
watched um you know I was watching a
couple episodes of uh of this before I
uh I came here I watched the YOLO One
and I watched the the blue face and uh
his baby mama yeah Jaden Jane Alexis
whatever yeah I think that's her name
yeah it's quite an episode that was um
that was quite the episode uh-huh you
know I think like I always
I just feel like when I see like
blueface and his baby mamas like damn
man
you know [__] could always be worse
you know if I think me and my girl are
like fighting too much I'm like man
that's a good way at least we're not
like [__] on each other on the
internet all day like
oh his baby Mama's music's so terrible
both of us baby oh it's brutal oh it's
so [__] bad it's terrible it's hey we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our partners at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to our family of
Odd Socks man look the most comfortable
socks in the entire world
odd Sox official
.com they just got the Coca-Cola license
they got the Scarface license they got
the WWE license they got [__]
Kool-Aid socks Chucky you know what I'm
saying Halloween's coming get them
[__] Chucky socks speaking of
Halloween what about the Ghostbuster
joints man oh these are gas
they even got the Ghostbuster underwear
what I'm trying to tell you is whatever
you're into they got them at Odd Socks
oddsocksofficial.com they just locked in
the brand new uh saving uh uh what's it
called
um
well look they got Transformers and
Power Rangers that's essentially what
I'm trying oh Hasbro the Hasbro license
all right they got all the socks draws
all that [__] plus they got The Odd
Socks Basics which are my favorite just
the normal guys I mean I wear them every
single day of my life they're literally
the most comfortable socks and don't
forget about the underwear ladies and
gentlemen the underwear are there if you
want to get 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg 20 off at checkout odd
socksofficial.com trust me all right you
go with some of these Odd Socks you put
them on it ain't the most comfortable
socks you ever put on your [__]
life you know what I'm saying DM me I'm
not gonna reply but they because you're
a liar yeah I mean anyway also want to
give a big shout out to our family at
King Palm baby that's right shout out to
King pong man listen I've been smoking
these King Palms since they've come on
board and I don't know what man look
bruh
these things right here
it's a tobacco-free leaf
just organic no no like uh no [__]
you know I'm saying just organic
I mean this thing right here this is
like it's it's natural what I like about
it you know what I'm saying now this is
what I like about King Palms is I went
from smoking just straight papers to
strictly King Palms and I love it
because I like the way they burn and I
like the way they taste because what
they do have are these terpene flavored
tips yes they're infused on the tip
tobacco-free you squeeze the tip
and it's a burst of flavor these are the
sugar punches shout out to Sugar Shawn
O'Malley uh these are the dragon fruits
we got grape they got all kinds of
flavors I mean literally watermelon they
got an energy drink flavor California
cream whatever it is and check this out
right now not only can you go and get
King Palm at your favorite smoke shop by
your house maybe 7-Eleven pop in get you
some King Palm whatever smoke shop is
near you has King Palms liquor stores
all that but you can also go to the
website and get 50 off half off whatever
you want to order from King Palm they
got the smoking accessories the ashtrays
the Grinders I mean the glass tips
whatever you're into kingpom.com promo
code bootleg say 50 off at checkout
shout out to King Palm man I'm about to
smoke up right now after this podcast
all right yo let's get back to the
interview you obviously uh also as
equally as a Avid drug user as you've
been over the years your Avid game uh
gamer
um what are your like
what was the game you first started
playing online like where people could
watch
um a lot of Call of Duty mainly okay it
was like all day just Call of Duty I
played a lot of that [__] that's kind of
how I got my first like following on
Call of Duty
because back in the day when they had
all those like big Call of Duty Clans on
YouTube kind of like how you know Face
Clan is now yeah I was in one that was
way smaller than that but I was in one
they had like um they had a pretty good
amount of Subs back then they had like I
think 300 000 on the channel so it was
great it was banging
um and I joined that I got a couple like
videos on there because I post videos
from the different people in there so I
got a couple videos on there got a
couple thousand subs and I dipped out
and I was like yeah I'm posting my [__]
now that's sick so so Call of Duty was
the wave yup Call of Duty was the wave
do you ever do [__] uh fortnite
no but you know what I have a lot of
good friends who came up like super hard
off fortnite yeah I just used to play a
shoot with my kid and I was such a [__]
I would just hide out and let everybody
me too dude I just build a [__] crib
and like sit in it I would just go to
the top of the tree house I would just
wait and I hope no one else try to come
up there yeah I'm just gonna camp and
snipe [__] that's exactly what
I do yeah my son would be like you're
[__] Noob like Bro [__] You what's
that mean that's why I stopped playing
dude everyone builds those big ass bases
so fast and I can't I can't build like
that it also feels like the gamer world
is like obviously you have your own
thing you're doing but that whole
YouTube gamer World feels [__] kind
of like douchey it's gotten to the point
where it was like cool to where it's
like
a lot of those dudes come off like
[__] douchebags yeah yeah I mean I um
you know being in like the Cod Clans
back in the day I remember I went to um
back in like 2018 I went to this event
called Pax and it's like this uh you
know they highlight a bunch of games and
[__] right and um a bunch of my like
other friends who did YouTube videos
also went out there we all flew out
there and I met like a bunch of these
dudes and one of the people uh a couple
of the people that I met were like just
super interesting and they had like
a ton of like followers and Subs at the
time you know and Hell of views but you
know the thing with gaming YouTube is
it's really tough to stay relevant
across multiple games you know like a
lot of these dudes that came up off one
of the Call of Duties yeah so you watch
that you watch them for that game almost
yeah like I knew who they were you know
we were in the same Clan but also like
people were watching them for that game
um and as the next game came out you
know a couple less people watch you know
and then I guess a new version of Call
of Duty yeah yeah you know oh [__] okay
yeah a lot of people like just changes
up every year every Cod you know it's
like it does it's almost like uh like
The Hunger Games every year you know
like who's gonna get hell of used new
Cod came out who's gonna [__] the bed
get no views you know I got to the point
where I felt like I was just too late
to get good because I would get on and I
would just be like I'm so trash now bro
I just I feel like I took like a
two-year break from playing that [__]
and then I got on and I just yep I was
just like dude I don't even like what am
I doing here I'm just running around for
five seconds before someone blows my
[__] head off yup Jesus Christ it's
not even fun I play Madden
oh Madden's tough though 2K Madden and
the WWE shoots fire WWE is fun I love
fun [__] around on it is uh
I mean do you do you like spend a lot of
money on VCU do you grab no so I'm I'm
bored I'm a board I'm an old school 2K
player my kids on that [__] they got
their little guys they run around and
play with each other and
I just play franchise mode bro
that's good I go old school no internet
needed see I play career because I like
to [__] around on 2K I heard it's fun
like my my kids were like it's the whole
world it is but I don't really give a
[__] about the world the only reason I I
even play that [__] is because I'll make
like a like a on on the computer you can
mod the game right I've heard so you can
make like super [__] up characters so
you can make a dude who's like four foot
eight you know and have to be like a you
know like a shooting guard you know so
you're just running around with a weird
[__] yeah yeah just like some [__]
up dude who like can't dunk but his only
stats are like you know close shooting
and like layups and [__] you know
um that's great it's just fun to [__]
around that's the only thing I did but
now it's like the career mode like you
have to spend money to have to to get
good and do anything and then the new
[__] they're doing like if you quit
during a game
like too many times they ban you yep I
like that [__] I should be able to quit
whatever the hell I want yeah just give
the guy the win and let me [__] yeah
that's how it's always been why would
they change it like that's how it's
always always been either given the win
or they just cancel out the game
um for you losing monetization on your
YouTube channel is a big deal yeah
heartbreaking it was yeah it was tough
you know for a while uh I had my
monetization luckily my second Channel
still has it but good so I'm just moving
a lot of your [__] to that channel no I
haven't really been posting [__] on
there honestly
um I just keep posting on the main you
know because I like posts in there it's
just crazy because like I wonder you
know I just saw somebody got likes what
was that what's that douchebag's name
fousey oh fousey you got the the uh I
don't call him a dude I don't know him
to call him a douchebag it's just based
on what I see online he you know he
might be a nice guy uh but I saw his his
page got demonetized or no fresh and
Fitz Paige got demonetized and they
cried on YouTube
they cried on their streets did it work
did they get it back no but I'm curious
how much do you pivot because you
already have like a big brand but how do
you pivot
like the business model
uh are you doing anything different to
try to make up for that money
I mean my business model hasn't really
changed at all you know uh I sell merch
you know I stream you got your merch
um a lot of collab like grinder drops my
friends grinder company
um we also uh you know I do sponsor
content you know fairly often there's a
good amount of weed Brands out there so
cut the check yeah you should is it kind
of like you're doing you know Dave
portnoy's One Bite Pizza review
have you do that for the weed [__]
pretty much that's pretty much yeah
um but it's not like all of it like a
lot of the companies you know I just buy
the weed to smoke the [__] you know but
then also you know sprinkle in a little
sponsored content it's it's not so bad I
mean but I mean I I gotta assume bro
you're like that's a big hit to your
pockets oh yeah don't get me wrong you
know I was making a good amount off
monetization but you know I also make
enough where I live comfortably and it's
smart that you're like you know I tell
that to anybody who does YouTube you
never know yeah 100 so it's like you got
to build up the other Revenue pack
streams because if not at any given time
the rug can get pulled from under you
yup and that's that's what happened to
me and I was fortunate enough that it
happened at a time where I already had
the other avenues built so it was
something where like damn I was pissed
off first couple months right um but I
didn't really have to like adjust my
lifestyle or anything is uh was is
Twitch as big or bigger of an earner for
you than YouTube was not not as big uh
twitch is a side thing but when I
combine it with the sponsor money and
then you know the merch it adds up to
enough yeah twitch [__] it's like I
heard that they're very like a they take
a big chunk right they do yeah stream on
kick now too okay kicks the new shot the
new [__] it's like the rumble of twitch
yeah see I like cake because they gave
me the username Goblin
so they're the only platform to ever do
that did they pay you for the no you
know they've heard they could cut some
checks yeah yeah we'll see but I don't
really stream enough right now uh I'm
more focused on other stuff
um I do a pie uh podcast Pine Park
um they're also like a weed brand that's
in dispensaries I'm part owner of that
so oh you're [__] great yep so how
many uh shelves are you guys on
um we're on shelves in Michigan Oklahoma
and California
that's sick dude congratulations yeah
it's looking good indoor I'm good what
was that indoor yeah it's good [__] it's
good [__] the [__] out here especially
is yeah you know it is interesting
because like people don't like
understand like if you get cookies I
just hashed on myself yes you did if you
get cookies like
in Cali at a dispensary and then you go
get it in Oklahoma it's not the same
people don't understand that because
they're like yo man the [__] cookie
[__] and so and so sucks and I'm like
because it's the grower who licensed the
[__] brand there you know what I'm
saying like
who's doing the distro who's doing the
growing like would you ever get involved
in uh any of the uh the the psilocybin
side of things man you know
a lot of people are getting involved in
it but I feel like it's just it's
sketchy and like like when are they
gonna clap down on that [__] it's coming
at some point well I think in Cali it's
always it's moving towards legalization
I think it is for for Therapeutics I
don't know enough about California like
laws and what's going on here really
therapeutic purposes at least because
they've already done that in Oregon I
think you can go and like see a
psychiatrist and do psilocybin therapy
but I think out here
Oakland San Francisco
I think that's it
it's fully decriminalized and I just
feel like it's got to come Cali Cali's
liberal as [__] yeah oh yeah it is you
always tax somebody I'm paying these
kinds they can't at least legalize
shrooms yeah give us something fun are
you because you know what I [__] hate
I love eating shrooms I [__] hate
eating weed though yes eating wheat is
the worst [__] ever who the [__] is that
Simba
I heard you had another dog here goblin
the goblin man what's going on man
it's good man pleasure to meet you
everybody's here pleasure man pleasure
to meet you hell yeah hello everybody
Welcome to the bootleg cave show I'm
here in the Next Room recording my album
I came in here to ask Kev where's the
marijuana
thank you let's take the whole box thank
you keep killing it hell yeah thank you
bro yeah pleasure
um
that's one of the hottest rappers in the
world right there just walking in
the weed
[Music]
one of the big
we're going to talk about I'm gonna come
talk to you soon
shout out to Simba what there that's
news with the random Cameo from Simba
[Laughter]
random Cameo from Simba just took the
King Palms box yeah but no I was asking
about eating weed because I [__]
think it's like the worst like Edibles I
hate Edibles dude I can't do it I
[__] throw up I hallucinate I feel
like I'm gonna die every time I got a
really high edible tolerance it's just
kind of how I've always been so you
could you could hang so I've done I did
a couple pretty crazy ones on stream I
did a like a like a 4 200 milligram on
stream wait wait wait for 420.
4 200 milligrams
of Edibles I was high for like two days
I was tripping
what happened
um so how it kind of played out is I
plan for 420 a couple years ago I was
like yo I'm gonna go no by the way of
milligram edible would have been
excessive yup so you plan this out
yeah I was like I was beginning to take
an RSO at the time are you familiar yeah
my dad does our yeah the drops right
love it love it bro it's great that's
what my dad does his lungs can't take
you can put it on whatever [__] you
know you can put on like a cracker and
just eat it you know you do whatever so
I had these like cookies
and I just squirted a gram on each one
and just ate that [__] and um it was
like about 80 percent THC in each one so
it was 800 milligrams each so came out
to 4 200 and I ate five of them
so
how did you feel man no it was like 4K
yeah 4K not 4200
like on the on I I feel like so the
first time it was kind of interesting
because the first day
I wasn't like that out of my mind like I
was kind of like okay I'm really [__]
high you know my body just felt
ridiculous I felt super heavy I felt
slumped but in my head I was like okay I
can kind of think right now like I'm not
I'm not that high I feel like
but I went to bed that night
and the next day I woke up way [__]
higher than I was the day before
and I was sitting there and I was just
like dude like
I was on FaceTime and I was I was like
slurring my words and [__] like I
couldn't talk normally and I was just
like I felt so stupid like you know when
you wake up super hungover and you're
just sitting there like what did I do
like yeah like wow I feel like 20 IQ
right now yeah why did I even do this it
never was worth it
yeah so I um I just felt dumb as [__]
and I was sitting there like I couldn't
function all day
and I was just like damn like I didn't
do anything I didn't [__] tweet on
Instagram I didn't post nothing I was
just sitting on the couch downstairs
playing Xbox and just losing every game
I played just getting [__] clapped I
couldn't hang that's so much weed yeah
it's you know I don't really take that
crazy of edible doses anymore I've
slowed down on it because you know
honestly it's just not fun there was a
period where I kind of wanted to like
test my limits be like okay it's not far
can I go and I found my limits you know
and if you smoke at least you could eat
that [__] off yeah yeah yeah you can
just chill out you know drink some water
you'll be having a little snack you
can't do anything no you're done you get
through it you're done go the [__] to
bed that's the only solution yeah I
always uh dude I had the most
psychedelic experience in my life off of
weed eating it though
like more than I've had a lot of shrooms
you know I've eaten a lot of shrooms at
once the most psychedelic experience in
my life is eating marijuana which I just
can't do it man I try to do it again
recently I think I ate like 25
milligrams
and I was [__] on my couch
[__] up bro the Edibles are just
different man it's nothing like smoking
there's nothing like you take dabs
um you know I've
I I've dabbed before I'm not a big
Dabber he's the Dabber this guy's got
the science where he he times so you
light the nail right and then he times
what is it you do
you gotta have the temperature yeah it's
too hot it'll [__] your lungs up right
exactly
I I dabbed with the Action Bronson once
and uh this was early on
first time I ever dab was with him and
this was early in the dab like craze if
you will it was probably 20.
13. oh you were smelling some [__]
oh yeah some poop soup dude some [__]
dude oh my god dude this Fool's like
I I have a YouTube Interview with him
that happened right after
and I'm blasted but
he gave me one hit and I it was like an
uncomfortable cough
like almost like I never had smoked
before type of cough where I was like oh
this this is this hurts yeah and he's
like oh but you gotta try a flavor
so he gave me another one right so I did
three hits within like
90 seconds to two minutes yep oh my god
dude then I watched Mac Miller [__]
just with a full band tripping the [__]
out dude it was like I was one of the
best concert experiences
I think I've ever had are you a big
music guy I wouldn't say like uh I
wouldn't say like a big big music guy
right
um but yeah
um I mean I mainly listen to rap yeah
um I listen you know it honestly depends
on the day you know sometimes I'll just
hop on Spotify and just see like what
they suggest me you know but usually
it's kind of [__] yeah just hit or miss
um but most of the time you know I
listen to a lot of Lucky Lucky's dope
Lucky's really good uh I used to not
listen to him but I started recently I
think his new [__] is really good by
listening to his new [__] I was like oh
now his old [__] sounds good you know
yeah so I went back and listened to that
um Playboy cardi if he would drop
anything would be awesome that would be
great to listen to are you a big Cardy
fan uh yeah yeah dilid is like one of my
favorite albums I [__] I play that
whole thing on much better than whole
lot of red I'll tell you that yeah yeah
dilid is one of my favorite I mean a
whole lot of red there's like a couple
songs on there dude you know I have
gotten to the point with cardi where
I'm just like
I missed the boat on this guys I don't
get it yeah like like I appreciate the
like he kind of pushed like you know
like he like sonically he'll do [__]
that was like different you know but I
just did I saw him live like twice and
each time I was just like he's just
screaming and running yep he's not even
performing his songs they just play
while he like shouts at the Devil yeah
yeah and does cardio and then there's
like a random white dude with a mohawk
next to him yeah he just got through
doing heroin for a month and then
decided to show up to the show and not
out on stage yeah his new shit's pretty
out there but his old stuff's really
good no I'm not mad at this I love his
old stuff I did like die lit yeah and
then I like all his [__] on the Cozy
tapes they said yep yep yeah shots shots
of Playboy cardi have you like had any
artist or anybody who you kind of grew
up looking up to like kind of like
see follow you or see like they kind of
know who you are um you're a fan of like
what you're doing I wouldn't say any I
really like grew up right liking you
know
um no not really uh when I was young
when I was like in Middle School in high
school and [__] it was all like Lil
Wayne you know he was he was like in
then you know it was like if you didn't
listen to Lil Wayne at the lunch table
get the [__] up you know like Lil Wayne
is the guy who I would uh
if like little Wayne passed me the lean
cup
you kind of have to you know you gotta
do it like [__] I guess I'm going
certain people you gotta smoke with yep
like if [__] what's the dude's name
uh Richards uh from [__] the Rolling
Stones a guy that's barely alive
the main guitarist
something Richards anyway if he wanted
to do like heroin with you you might
consider it you might yeah I wouldn't do
it but somebody would oh for sure for
sure quite a few people would yeah um
all right so you got merch that's
booming
um people can obviously how often do you
go online
um
it honestly past couple weeks I haven't
been posting [__] because I've been so
there's no like specific but no there's
no schedule it's sporadic but I post a
good amount usually like two three
videos a week I'll stream like probably
four or five days out of the week and
have you started to incorporate your
lady into the streaming at all are you
keeping her in really you know she
doesn't she doesn't really want to be
involved and you know I know [__]
some dudes like they got their girls are
on like their stream of them now and
[__]
you know I'm chilling you know I mean
there's one time she you know came in
and grabbed something from her she's
like a fan of yours initially right yeah
that's still yeah but you know it wasn't
really like a like a weird thing you
know it's just like
I don't know it was different for sure
it was a little like strange you know
because I felt like she knew a lot more
about me yeah because she didn't [__]
watches yeah yeah watching all my [__]
and I'm like damn you watched the Crack
video and you're still down like what's
up with you like what's wait you filmed
you doing crack no but I talked about it
oh you talked about it okay like what no
I didn't film that [__] like you and
your friends had crack in that kitchen
no we didn't film it
um damn dude well look I I think it's
dope like I just love the fact that like
I uncovered this whole new like you guys
are extremely successful
extremely popping like your page is
super dope
and I had no idea that like your sub
genre of content creation was a thing so
I was I'm fascinated by it dude I think
it's dope yeah it's a it's an awesome
Community dude it's like YouTube never
recommends our [__] so like you could
you have to have like real [__]
[__] with you yeah you gotta you
gotta like find the [__] you know you
gotta it's like almost like a word of
mouth thing damn near because very few
of our videos end up getting recommended
you know do you do it any like you gotta
tick tocks keep getting banned so that's
not a thing yep uh do you put anything
up on Facebook no I just do Twitter
Instagram and uh YouTube and twitch you
should do a Snapchat show I used to use
Snapchat a lot but listen the Snapchat
show
have you been on there and you could see
the original show yeah yeah dude they're
giving those shows to some people I got
one it really makes a lot of money they
pay they pay [__] like you could do like
how do you get into that though like how
do you do you reach connection with a
guy you can appreciate it you could do
like your types of videos you could do
like Goblin commentates do you ever do
commentary [__] yeah I do a lot you
could just do that about like pop
culture and dude it'll just feed the
algorithm and they pay
nicely I would love a Snapchat check
dude Snapchat administrators out there
you gotta tap in man
um any collabs coming up I know uh like
for you when you say you had the grinder
[__] going on do you ever collab with
any of the other guys in your community
yeah you know I do a lot of stuff with
Yola Eric Khan you know those are the
homies
um I'm planning on um getting involved
in my podcast pretty soon I'm gonna be
doing one are you filming it out here
yeah oh yeah is the Marty guy helping no
actually it's my homies in Pine Park oh
sick
that's dope yeah it's gonna be fun
interview based yeah yeah mainly but
I'll have some solo episodes yeah I
think you have a great I think anybody
who can like talk by themselves and be
entertaining that's such a hard thing to
do 100 yeah it's it's uh you watch a lot
of videos and it's just like cut every
like three seconds yeah it's cut like or
like people if they are talking like
hoopla it's hoopla it's drama that maybe
people are interested in or even then
it's like a lot of podcasts like you got
to kind of have a guess there to bounce
[__] off of because like it's not easy
to just carry a interesting conversation
to tell a story definitely people who
aren't sitting in front of you yep that
shit's tough dude it's a skill so I'm
sure the podcast is going to be fire
hell yeah thank you bro appreciate it
I'm excited for it dude you should come
on I'm down dude let's do it you haven't
launched it yet no not yet it's coming
soon
I like that yeah the gobcast coming soon
uh do you have a website people go by
the merch goblin420.com it's the spot
for all the goods welcome to La yep
thank you so much I'm loving it so far
we're gonna be able to print money out
here because all these weed companies
are mostly ran by idiots and they have
money and they they just they're really
good at setting money on fire yeah so if
that's where you come in and yeah up
take it take it [__] yeah I'm looking
forward to it I'll be like a shark all
you gotta know is if you go downtown
you know what in your world I'm going to
tell you what you're going to run into
you're going to run into the guys
downtown who have the high-rise condos
and you walk in and it's like a [__]
weed Walmart in every building downtown
all the Trappers there's a Trapper on
every floor to every high price
high-rise in downtown L.A really if
you're in downtown L.A and you see
random [__] with suitcases
they're trapping there's pounds of weed
in those suitcases damn like Rob them or
like no I mean
Trump ah [__] yeah put that out there
never mind don't Rob anybody I didn't
plan on it I was just you know yeah
you're about to eat though man
congratulations welcome to La man good
to meet you yes sir yeah thanks for
having me likewise go check this guy out
goblin420.com IG which IG the gbln and
then YouTube is Goblin just Goblin yeah
that's you got that uh well if you type
me in I come up first
yeah man I'm there baby there it is I
appreciate you pulling up brother hell
yeah thank you so much for having me was
a good one yes sir Banger fire hey what
up man uh you just watched another
episode of the bootleg cab podcast
brought to you by hardean baby shout out
to the family at hardean don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they're gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at hardine in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardine go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine